toi tu fais pour pourquoi aussi bien
dormir
et mon texan de 5 à 42 56 548 je vous en
parlais par les monstres pu [ __ ] je
crois que tu as en ronde de la tourette
tuer beaucoup se réconcilient non une
robe le mans qui a plus rien à sauver le
coup
qu'est-ce que vous l'info n'était pas dû
à la yates émis hier avant-hier j'ai
enchaîné six minutes suite si tu as
jamais tenir
je perds tu gardes noise est pas
possible à trouver des solutions plutôt
d'apprendre une infirmière à domicile de
quelqu'un pour te faire le ménage campus
comme si j'étais ma grand-mère
de son site non c'est pas possible un
surveillant matheron tu vas parler j'ai
envie d'entendre c'est tout ça n'est pas
l'oubli j'ai écouté macron vous n'êtes
pas non plus un martyr je peux repartir
on trouve ça normal vous tirent dessus à
votre âge pour moi l'âge mais pourquoi
vous battez c'est pathétique
en fait chier avec panache
parce que je voulais c'était que
monsieur mâcon ils viennent nous voir et
nous disent on va parler le problème
c'est que notre colère un nouveau repas
léger du monde
dans la merde si l'on peut acheter la
mer j'ai mon cou qui expose et je vais
pouvoir passer et ma copine me dit tu
n'es pas tout seul d'accord tu confirmes
ans de sursis plus possible
vous avez des lits disponibles parce
qu'on commence à avoir beaucoup trop de
monde il ya plus de kétamine sa loge
pour en trouver l'argent n'a pu bush -
je vous admire un saison si on ne vous
savez moi je pense que je vais pierre
petites affaires ça va un moment de
donner de sa personne tout le temps tout
le temps tout le temps et de ne pas
sentir qu'on nous respecte ni moulineaux
de travail
[Musique]
vous êtes un mari ou fait il n'ya pas
toujours des maris je les faisais des
100 je sais pas